merci merci pour la concision et la
force de ceux de ce2 ce propos et je
vais maintenant avoir la réaction de
madame karine charbonnier finale die qui
est industriel qui a donc responsables
d'entreprises chefs d'entreprise par
rapport à 7 à cette vision qui
finalement au départ est une vision
sociétale beaucoup plus large que
finalement une vision unique de
modification de refonte de ce code du
travail
moi je me réjouis vivement de l'idée
actuelle qui al'air largement partagée
de redescendre au niveau de la
négociation collective
l'évolution du code du travail néanmoins
j'ai une grande inquiétude sur le fait
que pour descendre au niveau de la
négociation collective les discussions
sur le code du travail il faut
absolument que les parties en présence
soit représentative est légitime dans le
système actuel c'est absolument pas le
cas on parle on utilise le vocable
démocratie sociale mais c'est pas une
démocratie c'est un totalitarisme social
qui est basé sur des élections de
monopole d'une part donc je me réjouis à
ce titre qu'on commence à lire de plus
en plus qu'il faut mettre fin au
monopole soucier de présentation
candidat mais libéré le monopole des des
élections est totalement insuffisant
puisque les salariés liste des élus qui
ne participent pas à la signature des
contrats c'est le délégué syndical qui
signe les accords d'entreprise au mépris
de l'élection d'entreprise
donc je pense que si on dit il faut
faire sauter le monopole syndical
la logique complète c'est de dire en
même temps il faut que ce soit les élus
qui signe les accords d'entreprise
autrement ça n'a aucun sens de supprimer
le monopole puisqu'on continue à lire
des élus qui ne peut qu ils ne peuvent
pas prendre de décision dans
l'entreprise c'est très important parce
que le délégué syndical ça a été dit un
petit peu plus tôt mais c'est vraiment
important de le rappeler
c'est une intrusion c'est une ingérence
extérieure du syndicat dans l'entreprise
dans une entreprise qui ne connaît pas
nous t'y connais pas les membres et qui
est extrêmement forte puisque par
l'intermédiaire du mandat le syndicat
des sites qui veut qui est le délégué
syndical de l'entreprise et il peut le
démettre à tout instant moi dans mon
entreprise en deux ans au monde et des
gays syndicale enfin un des délégués
syndicaux a été démis par le syndicat
extérieur parce que prenait des
positions qui était pas conforme à la
position du responsable de l'union
locale qui est parfois beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus extrémiste que le syndicat
national donc c'est vraiment important
si on veut développer les accords
d'entreprise de ne pas construire sur du
sable et commencez vraiment par un socle
solide et des mots qui construire une
vraie démocratie sociale qui correspond
pas tant un désir des chefs d'entreprise
mais avant tout des salariés français
s'est donné une liberté une possibilité
de participer aux salariés français et
je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
opportunité politique en plus là dessus
le fruit me paraît largement mieux
alors ensuite quand on parle de
négociations collectives
je pense que on met un petit peu parfois
dans le même sac les accords
d'entreprise et les négociations de
branche
j'ai même entendu un petit peu plus tôt
ce matin qu'on disait dans les petites
entreprises
on peut pas faire d' accord d'entreprise
donc c'est la jungle s'il n'y a pas
d'accord de branche
moi je voudrais quand même m'arrêter sur
ce sur ce point parce que ça me paraît
pas du tout évident que c'est la jungle
quand il n'y a pas d'accord de branche
je voudrais rappeler qu'en allemagne par
exemple seuls 60% des salariés sont
couverts par des accords de branche
non pas parce qu'il manque des branches
mais parce que les branches ne sont pas
étendus par la loi que les entreprises
adhèrent librement ou non aux branches
et que ça fait toute la différence parce
que ça veut dire que les branches en
cette concurrence du secteur libre on va
dire et sont peut-être en clin à prendre
les positions un petit peu plus
attractives notamment dans les rapports
que vous évoquez l instant entre les
grandes et les petites entreprises
est ce que pour autant en allemagne
c'est la jungle quand 40% des salariés
sont pas couvertes par les accords de
branche je pense pas c'est vraiment
important de comprendre que l'extension
par la loi des accords de branche c'est
une spécificité
à ma connaissance très française qui me
paraît très totalitaire aussi d'autant
qu' il y en a toujours ce problème de
légitimité des partenaires sociaux alors
qu'est ce que c'est un accord de branche
peut on va dire une convention ça c'est
ma convention donc elle n'est pas aussi
et parce que le code du travail mais
elle est pas négligeable non plus je les
prises avec moi rien que dans les
départements du nord et du pas de calais
pour la métallurgie et laquelle
j'appartiens nous avons cette convention
différentes
donc j'ai des sites également dans les
vosges et les ardennes donc je travaille
avec trois conventions différentes
alors on parle de les harmoniser
aujourd'hui alors de quoi parle-t-on
quand on dit qu'il faut les harmoniser
une convention ça parle valeur de la
prime vacances valeur de la prime
casse-croûte ça existe encore faut-il
payer la prime d'équipé pendant les
congés ou pas je veux qu'elle est la
couverture du jour de carence
autant d'exemples je suis désolé
d'entrer dans ces détails triviaux mais
autant d'exemples dont je me demande
franchement pourquoi ce au niveau d'une
branche qu'on discute ça ça me paraît
être clairement des éléments qui
relèvent de l'entreprise et pas des
branches entre une un groupe de dizaines
de milliers de personnes à une tpe
pourquoi on va fixer ensemble dans le
domaine de la métallurgie la prime
vacances rien pour moi les trois
conventions qui me concerne la prime
vacances elle oscille de 200 à 600 euros
on va demander aux partenaires sociaux
non légitime d'harmoniser ça donc on va
aligner 600 euros et se retrouve à
mettre les gens dans la rue à 200 enfin
c'est ça aucun sens
on parle de d'adaptation modèle
économique de d'économie flexible et et
on va mettre ça dans des accords de
branche
je pense que vraiment
le niveau conventionnelles les
partenaires sociaux ça me paraît ça me
paraît vraiment pas adéquat discuter des
sujets qui sont dans les conventions
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
réinventer le rôle de la branche comme
prestataire de services comme médiateur
quand il ya des conflits dans
l'entreprise comme organe de discussions
avec le pouvoir politique pour la
gestion des formations la gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois mais dans le
cadre actuel je pense qu'il ya une vraie
réflexion à avoir sur les conventions il
faut redescendre au niveau de
l'entreprise
j'ajoute aussi parce qu'on parle au
niveau de l'entreprise des délires il
faut faire des référendums bien dans les
petites entreprises n'y a pas de
représentants syndicaux
une fois qu'on a fait sauter le monopole
syndical et qu'on négocie avec des élus
et plus avec des délégués syndicaux
la question du référendum ou du dialogue
social dans les tpe ne se pose plus
puisque on a des personnes avec qui
discuter
donc je vois là juste un dernier point
peut-être parce que il est très
important sur le lit le licenciement
c'est vrai que par rapport à notre
problème de chômage réformer le donnait
la possibilité licenciés c'est
indispensable
on a déjà dit donc je passe rapidement
notre droit il n'est pas
fondamentalement différente ce qui se
passe en angleterre ou en allemagne tout
le problème c'est l'application par les
tribunaux moi je pense que les tribunaux
remettre en cause fondamentalement par
rapport à nos voisins anglais et
allemands que je connais serait bien
remettre en cause la liberté
d'organisation la liberté d'entreprendre
des entreprises on conteste tout le
temps la capacité de jugement des chefs
d'entreprise on va dire quand un salarié
est insuffisant ou incompétent on va
dire c'est l'entreprise qui est pas
capable de former ou qui forment
inefficacement ou qui sait pas mettre en
garde google voilà il faut faire des
tonnes de recommander ça se pratique pas
du tout comme ça ailleurs et je pense
que il faut réfléchir dans la loi à
rééquilibrer les droits des salariés
la liberté d'entreprendre parce que
cette liberté d'entreprendre elle est
complètement occulté par les tribunaux
et dans le cas de la flexisécurité qui
est quelque chose dont on aime bien ce
mot est à juste titre on essaie de le
copier
on a beaucoup travaillé sur les droits à
la formation des salariés on a déjà un
corpus législatif très important sur ce
sujet et on a complètement oublié
d'équilibré ça avec la liberté de lys
enfin je veux pas remettre en cause le
droit
le motif réel et sérieux licenciements
mais le la possibilité de licencier
c'est vraiment le recto verso des droits
à la formation et du rexy sécurité je
pensais vraiment important d'articuler
cette idée de licenciement et formation
droit à la formation dans le cadre de la
flexisécurité